[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JONATHAN GRUBER: Externalities,
so, so far in the class,
we once again remember
the big picture.
We started with the
first fundamental theorem
overall for economics, which
is that the competitive market
will maximize total
social welfare.
Then we said that will not
be true under conditions
of market failure.
Remember, market failure
doesn't mean market collapse.
It means when there are
barriers to the market achieving
this first best outcome, OK?
One barrier is
imperfect competition.
One barrier was
imperfect information.
A third barrier to
welfare maximization
or a third source of market
failure is externalities, OK?
That's the third source
of market failure,
and we're going to
talk about that today.
What is an externality?
Let me be very clear
about the definition.
An externality occurs
whenever one party's actions
makes another party
better or worse off, OK?
Let's do it-- let's
make it a person,
whether my actions make
you better or worse off,
but I don't bear the
consequences of that.
So, when my actions make
you better or worse off,
but I don't bear
the consequences,
then there's an externality.
So let's talk about
that in the context.
Let's start with the classic
example of externalities, which
is a negative
production externality,
a negative production
externality, OK?
The classic example
is you've got a river.
On that river is a steel plant.
That steel plant
produces steel, OK?
But, as a byproduct
of that production,
it dumps sludge
into the river, OK?
You guys remember The Lorax?
So it's basically The Lorax, OK?
So, basically, the steel plant
dumps sludge into the river,
OK?
That sludge floats down the
river and kills the fish.
Those killed fish mean that
fishermen cannot make as much
money fishing on the river, OK?
So, basically, there's sludge
coming out of the factory,
and that sludge we're going
to make the assumption
is directly proportional
to the production of steel.
So we're going to say, for
every unit of steel produced,
there's one unit of sludge
that emits on the factory just
to make this model easy.
So, every unit of steel,
there's one unit of sludge.
That sludge flows down the
river and kills the fish.
Unfortunately, there
are fishermen down
this river who are
trying to catch fish,
and that hurts their
livelihood, OK?
So this is a classic
example of living
by an externality, because
the steel plant's behavior is
imposing a cost
on the fishermen.
Their sludge is imposing
a cost on the fishermen,
but the steel plant doesn't
bear any consequence of that.
They just dump the sludge
and forget about it, OK?
So that's what we
mean by negative.
It's a negative externality
because my actions
are hurting you.
The steel plant's actions
are hurting the fishermen.
It's a production externality
because it comes out
of the production process,
in this case, for steel.
So that's what we mean
by negative production
externality.
It means that, when one
party's production adversely
affects another party, but
the party doing the production
doesn't bear any
consequences of that, then
that's a negative
production externality.
So what effect does that have?
Let's go to figure 22-1
and talk graphically
about how we think about
production externalities, OK?
This is the market for steel.
In figure 22-1 is
the market for steel,
the quantity of steel on the
x-axis, the price of steel
on the y-axis, OK?
The market is initially
in equilibrium at point A.
That is where demand, which is
the downward-sloping blue line,
equals supply, which is
upward-sloping blue line.
Now, as we said, in a
perfectly competitive market,
demand represents the
marginal willingness
to pay for the good, which is
equal to the marginal benefit
that consumers get from
consuming the good, OK?
The marginal benefit
of consuming the good
is the marginal
willingness to pay.
And that's what's represented
by the demand curve, OK?
We're not going to
touch that here.
We're going to leave
that alone, OK?
The supply curve is the firm's
marginal willingness to supply,
which is their
marginal cost, OK?
So, in the perfectly
competitive market
where marginal benefit
equals marginal cost,
we get equilibrium.
And that yields the
welfare-maximizing outcome.
The market succeeds.
It does not fail, OK?
The difference now
is we're now going
to drive a wedge between
privately perceived
benefits and social benefits.
So, for the consumption of
steel with the demand curve,
we're going to see the
benefit to individuals
is the benefit to society.
They're one and the same.
That's what we've
assumed all course.
But, for the supply
of steel, we're
going to say wait a second.
The benefit to society is
different than the benefit
to the steel producers.
Or I'm sorry.
The cost to society is different
than the cost to the steel
producers.
The cost to the steel
producers, which
is their private marginal
cost, is the supply curve,
but the social marginal
cost adds the damage
they're doing to the fishermen.
That is society encompasses
all the actors in society.
It encompasses both the steel
plant and the fishermen.
So the marginal cost
to society is the cost
of producing the steel plus
the marginal damage being
done to the fishermen.
So social marginal cost
equals private marginal cost
plus marginal damage.
Social marginal cost equals
private marginal cost
plus the marginal damage.
And we see that as the red line.
What that means, from a welfare
perspective, what we care about
is social marginal
benefits and costs, not
private marginal
benefits and costs.
So what that means is
the social optimum,
the welfare-maximizing optimum,
is actually at point C. Point
C is the welfare-maximizing
optimum where
the social marginal cost equals
the social marginal benefit,
OK?
And, therefore, we overproduce.
What's happening is
the steel company,
not considering
the damage they're
doing through production to the
fisherman, produces too much.
The steel company
produces at the point
where private
marginal cost equals
private marginal benefit,
which, in our case,
equals social
marginal benefit, OK?
That's the private
market decision.
But, in fact, it should
be producing at the point
where social
marginal cost equals
private marginal benefit,
private marginal benefit--
equals social
marginal benefit, OK?
And the point where
social marginal cost
equals social marginal
benefit is lower production.
Why?
Because lower
production avoids--
reduces the damage being done
to the fishermen down the river,
OK?
So the optimum, from
society's perspective,
is point C. In other words,
there is a market failure.
The private market
is not delivering
the welfare-maximizing outcome.
And we can see that
creates a deadweight loss.
The deadweight loss
is the units that
are traded that are
socially inefficient.
Why are they
socially inefficient?
They're privately efficient.
If you see Q2 and Q1, before
we introduced externalities,
we'd say, well, it's a shame if
they don't get produced, right?
If we ignore
externalities, we'd say,
Q2 and Q1, well, they have a
benefit higher than their cost.
So they should get produced.
But, actually, in a
world of externalities,
their benefit is
lower than their cost
because their cost incorporates
the damage done to the fish.
So there's a deadweight loss.
Critically, remember,
you've got to know
how to draw these
deadweight loss triangles.
Remember, deadweight
loss triangles
always point to the optimum.
The deadweight lost triangle
is the area ABC, OK?
It's drawn-- it's
units that are sold
where the social
marginal cost exceeds
the social marginal benefit.
And that's that
deadweight loss triangle.
So there's an
inefficiency arising
from the fact the
private actors do not
account for the social
implications of their actions,
OK?
Questions about that?
So we have here a
classic example,
perhaps the classic example
in all of economics,
of a market failure.
The classic example
is a market failure
happens when the social
implications of your actions
are different than the
private implications
since people maximize their
own private well-being.
That's what Adam Smith
sort of taught us.
The notion of the
invisible hand is
that the market acting
in its own interests
will deliver the best
outcomes for society.
We're saying, no,
that's not true
if the market's
own interests has
implications for other parties
that are not accounted for, OK?
Now externalities don't have to
just be on the production side.
We can also have negative
consumption externalities.
That would be a case where
my literally consuming a good
makes you worse off.
My consuming a good
makes you worse off, OK?
So let me start with
a simple question.
Let's start with a perfectly
competitive market.
If I consume a good, I
raise demand for that good.
That raises the price.
Is that an externality?
In a perfectly competitive
market, it's not.
Why isn't that an externality?
If I consume the--
if I want to consume the
good, the price goes up.
Everyone pays a higher price.
Why is that not an externality?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Because you
also bear the cost.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Because
you also bear the costs.
An externality only
occurs when you don't
bear the costs of your actions.
When you want a car, and,
therefore, the price of cars
goes up, you pay
that higher price.
Externalities only
occur when you
don't bear the consequences.
So, in general,
consumption externalities
don't happen through
causing higher prices.
Consumption externalities
happen more directly when
my consumption affects you.
So the best example of
this would be smoking, OK?
When I smoke, it affects you.
It affects you in
a number of ways.
Most directly, if I
smoke in this classroom,
you get secondhand smoke,
and you get ill as a result.
But that's not all.
It affects you because, if
I smoke, and I get sick,
and my health care costs go
up, then, well, I work at MIT.
All my fellow MIT employees
bear those costs because we all
share health insurance.
And, when I retire,
all society bears
those costs because
those costs are
paid for by the
Medicare program, which
is financed by taxation.
So my health care costs
are an externality.
Secondhand smoke
is an externality.
What are some other
externalities from smoking?
What are other externalities
that can occur from smoking?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Environmental
damage from the production.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Well,
that would be a production
externality, OK?
We're going to leave
that alone for now.
I'm just talking about
from consuming cigarettes.
From consuming cigarettes, what
else-- what other damage comes?
So I make you--
I may make you sick
through secondhand smoke.
I might raise health care costs.
Well, I might raise
health care costs, OK?
What else is
another externality?
What else does smoking do?
Well, it turns out
there are 100,000.
This is a number which I
triple check because I still
can't believe it.
100,000 people every
single year die
in fires caused by
smokers, not in the US,
worldwide, which
is a crazy number.
But, if you think about how
tightly packed slums are
in developing
countries, one person
falling asleep with
their cigarette burning
can kill thousands
of people, OK?
That is an externality
because my action to smoke
has killed you, OK?
And I'm clearly not going
to compensate you for that.
So that's another
externality, OK?
What about the fact that smokers
are less productive at work.
They have to take
more smoke breaks.
They might get sick more often.
Is that an externality or not?
The fact that smokers are
less productive at work,
is that an externality or not?
And why or why not?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Not necessarily
because, if they're
less productive, they're
going to do less work
and get paid less.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Exactly,
it's not an externality
if they're paid less.
This is the key thing, which is
it's only an externality if you
don't bear the consequences.
If smokers are less
productive at work,
and they get paid
less as a result
by exactly the same amount
they're less productive,
there's no externality.
But, if their wage
doesn't fully adjust,
and, therefore, their
lower productivity
affects everybody else in the
firm or the firm's profits,
that is an externality, OK?
So this is the deep
aspect of externalities.
You have to think
about whether people
are compensating for it, OK?
You have to think about that.
OK, most importantly, the
fact I kill myself by smoking
is not an externality, OK?
Smokers die seven years
earlier on average.
Roughly speaking, every
cigarette you smoke
lowers your life
by seven minutes.
It's pretty linear, OK?
But you know what?
If I sit by myself on a rock
in the middle of nowhere
and smoke until I die, no
problem because, in that case,
the social implications are
the private implications.
I've made my privately
optimal decision,
and there's no effect
on anybody else.
So it's also socially optimal.
There's only an externality if
we have one these mechanisms,
like if I'm smoking, I'm in
the woods, and I start a fire,
and the fire
company has to come.
That's an externality.
But, as long as I
just sit by myself,
and I don't bother anybody--
I just smoke until I die--
there's no externalities, OK?
So externalities come through
the effects on others.
So let's think about the
externalities of smoking.
Let's think about a negative
consumption externality, OK?
Here we have the
market for cigarettes.
On the x-axis, we
have the number--
I'm sorry, figure 22-2.
On the x-axis, we
have the number
of cigarettes, quantity
of cigarettes consumed.
On the y-axis, we have the
price of cigarettes per pack.
We have an initial
equilibrium at point A, which
is where the private
marginal benefit equals
the private marginal cost.
Here we're going
to assume there's
no externalities from
producing tobacco.
Let's assume there's no
sludge produced, whatever.
That's a separate issue, OK?
There may be production
externalities too.
We covered those.
You already know how
to think about those.
But here let's assume
there aren't any.
Let's assume the
social marginal cost
equals the private
marginal cost,
no production externalities.
But there is a
consumption externality.
Every cigarette I smoke
is bad for society.
What that means is the
social marginal benefit
is below the private
marginal benefit.
The social marginal benefit is
the private marginal benefit
minus the marginal
damage I'm doing.
MD is the Marginal Damage,
the marginal damage I'm doing.
That's estimated to be about--
absent secondhand smoke, the
damage of smoking is about
$0.50 a pack.
The secondhand smoke
part is really hard,
and the estimates are anywhere
from $0.01 to $2 per pack.
So that's hard to know
how big that is, OK?
But, certainly, we have
this negative consumption
externality, which
is that, basically,
every pack of cigarettes I smoke
is worth at least $0.50 less
to society than it's worth to
me because I have these external
effects on society and
perhaps a lot more than that.
As a result, I should smoke--
I choose to smoke at point
A, but the social optimum
is point C.
So, once again, I've
created a deadweight loss.
Once again, I'm over consuming.
There's overconsumption here.
Just like there was
overproduction of steel.
There's overconsumption
and a deadweight loss
because there are units that are
privately optimal to consume,
but not socially optimal.
Now, externalities, this
is kind of a fun topic
because it is interesting.
I talk-- so let's talk for a
second about secondhand smoke
and whether that's
actually an externality.
So almost all the damage
of secondhand smoke
is not done by
smoking in a crowd.
It's done to family members.
Almost all the damage
of secondhand smoke
is done to family members.
Mostly, it's that you make your
family members sick by smoking.
Is that an externality?
When or when is it not an--
under what conditions might
it not be an externality?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Well, I guess it
wouldn't be an externality
if like let's say you die.
And then the consequences
of them getting sick
doesn't affect you at all.
Or, well, I guess it--
JONATHAN GRUBER: No, no, then
it-- no, then it would be.
OK, so what-- under what
conditions-- under what
conditions would it
not be an externality?
When-- yeah?
STUDENT: If your-- like,
if your family gets sick,
and you are impacted by that.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yeah, if
I care about my family,
in particular, if I
maximize family utility,
then it's not an externality.
If I maximize not
my own utility,
but my family's utility, then
I will essentially internalize,
internalize, the externality.
Just like a lower wage means
that I bear the consequences
for being a less productive
worker, if I care
about my whole
family's happiness,
and I make my kids
sick by smoking,
then my smoking
decision will actually
reflect the total
consequences for my family.
I will smoke only if it's
optimal for my family for me
to do so.
It doesn't mean I won't smoke.
It just means I must--
I'll have to enjoy it
enough that it's worth
making my kids sick, OK?
It doesn't mean that's
an incorrect decision
because, after all, the
odds are you don't make
your kids that
sick, and, you know,
you might like
smoking a lot, OK?
It's just that you will
internalize the externality
because you only
smoke to the extent
that it is optimal
for the whole family.
So it's not necessarily
an externality, OK?
So we'd like, actually, to test
whether it's an externality.
There's actually a
clever test of this,
which is there's a test of
whether people maximize family
utility, which is, if people
maximize family utility,
what would be the
implications of giving
a father $1 versus
giving a mother $1?
If both the father
and the mother
are maximizing a family
utility function,
the same family
utility function, then
should it matter whether I
give $1 to a father or $1
to a mother?
No, it shouldn't because
that's $1 to the family.
We're maximizing family utility
subject to a family budget
constraint.
It shouldn't matter
who gets the dollar.
So one test of family
utility maximization
is does it matter
who gets the money.
And it turns out
it does a lot, OK?
So there was a
great test of this.
In the UK, they used to have a
tax system where, essentially,
there was a credit they
gave for every kid.
And the way the
credit worked is there
would be a check sent home, OK?
Then they changed it.
So, instead, they
said, well, instead
of sending a check
home, we're just
going to add it into
pay, into wages.
So, instead of getting
a check sent home,
we're just going to
raise your wages.
Well, it had no effect
on family budgets.
They literally just changed it.
The difference was, back
in-- this was in the '70s.
Men worked and women didn't.
So, when the check came
home, women controlled it.
But, when it was in
wages, men controlled it.
So, if there's family
utility maximization,
it shouldn't matter.
But it turned out, as
soon as they changed
the way they paid it,
spending on kids went down,
and spending on
drugs and alcohol
went up because,
basically, guys don't care
about kids as much as women do.
Sorry, guys.
It's just-- I don't know what
the evolutionary biology is.
At least, in the
'70s, they didn't.
So that's a rejection of
family utility maximization.
Who had the dollars
actually mattered.
It's kind of a
neat study for how
you think about these theories.
So it suggests that, secondhand
smoke, probably, people
don't perfectly
maximize family utility.
So there probably are
some externalities, OK?
So that's a negative
consumption externality.
There can also, of course,
be positive externalities.
So let's talk about a positive
consumption externality.
Let's talk about my neighbor.
I don't get along
with my neighbor, OK?
And, partly, it's
because my neighbor
has a habit of
starting big projects
and leaving them half done.
And, about 25 years
ago, 20 years ago,
he started a big project
to landscape his yard,
created these huge
mounds of dirt
that I look at directly from
my kitchen, and then stopped.
So, for 20 years, I've had to
stare at huge mounds of dirt,
OK?
Now let's think about
my neighbor's decision
to go ahead and get rid
of those piles of dirt.
Let's say that that
would cost $1,000.
So the cost is $1,000, OK?
And let's say the
benefit to my neighbor
from doing so is clearly
less than $1,000,
or he would have done it.
Let's say it's $800.
So that's why he leaves
those piles of dirt
because the cost is
$1,000 to remove them,
and it's only worth $800 to him.
But what he's not accounting
for is, if he removed them,
there'd be a positive benefit
to me of another $300.
So, actually, the
total social benefit
of removing the dirt piles is
higher than the social cost.
So, from a social
perspective, he should do it,
but he doesn't because,
privately, it's
not optimal to do so.
So that is a positive
consumption externality.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Does this mean you'd
be willing to pay him like $200
to do it?
JONATHAN GRUBER:
Well, this leads
to a very deep question, which
is can't all externalities
simply be internalized.
Let's take this example.
Why can't I just go over
and offer to pay him, OK?
Well, and, in fact, with
any example, we can do that.
Why can't the fishermen just
go pay the steel plant, OK?
Why can't you pay me not
to smoke in class, OK?
Indeed, with any of
these externalities,
there's a question why can't
they all be internalized.
And, indeed, there's
a school of thought,
which suggests that
externalities aren't really
a problem.
They can all just
be internalized.
But, of course, that's
totally wrong, OK?
Let's start with a hard example.
Let's talk about the biggest
environmental externality,
which is global warming, OK?
With global warming, every
single time you drive,
you are bringing
people of Bangladesh
that much closer to
being under water.
How could you possibly
negotiate that?
How could you possibly negotiate
where the people of Bangladesh
would come and say, well,
drive a little bit less
so I don't go under water?
OK, that's not happening, OK?
But, even with these simple
cases, think about this.
Why can't I just go to my
neighbor and offer him $200?
There's three problems.
First problem is there's
the fact that I don't really
know what his costs are
and what his benefits are
and that I might--
I don't want to offer more than
I have to to get him to do it,
OK?
The second problem is he
doesn't know how I feel.
So there's an
information asymmetry,
which makes negotiations hard.
There's a third
problem too, which
is it'd just be deeply
weird to do that, right?
I mean, it's just not
how society works.
You think about a classic
case of an externality you've
probably all run into, which
is your neighbor playing
their music too loud, OK?
If your neighbor plays
their music too loud,
that is an externality
on you, OK?
Now, in principle, you
could go to your neighbor
and say, well, look,
I'm studying for a test.
This test will raise
my grade by 10 points.
A higher grade in this
class will raise my earnings
by $1,000.
So I'm willing to pay you $83 to
stop playing music because I've
calculated my lifetime
earning effect
of your playing the music.
OK, even at MIT, that would
be sort of deeply weird to do.
So what do you do?
You either shut up about
it, or you go yell at them.
OK, but yelling induces--
it's not necessarily
an efficient way
to resolve it because maybe they
really want to play the music.
The efficient thing would be,
if it's worth more than $83
for them to play the
music, they should
get to play it and
just pay you $83.
But, in fact, that doesn't work.
So, in fact, private
solutions to these problems
simply do not work, OK?
It's just hard to figure out
how you can really get people
privately to internalize
these externalities
because negotiation is difficult
and because it's just socially
awkward.
There is a famous
apocryphal story
told of a famous economist
who was on a flight
and wanted to get
work done and couldn't
because the person next to
him wouldn't stop talking.
So they actually offered
them $10 to shut up.
I don't believe that
actually happened,
but, you know, it makes
for a good story, OK?
So that's a positive
consumption externality.
Finally, we have positive
production externalities.
The classic example of
a positive production
externality is R&D
by private firms, OK?
When a firm does
research and development,
they don't just create
learning for themselves.
They create learning that might
benefit other firms as well,
OK?
And, indeed, the best
economic estimates
suggest that the social
returns to $1 of R&D
are 2 and 1/2 times
the private returns,
that every dollar
of R&D a firm does
benefits society
by 2 and 1/2 times
how much it benefits the firm.
And, as a result, firms
under invest in R&D, OK?
As a result, firms
And they are-- and
that's leading them to--
that's leading to too little
R&D being done in society,
and that affects all of us
because that affects growth.
That's what my new book
Jumpstarting America
is all about.
It's about why we
need the government
to come in and invest more in
R&D because firms under invest,
OK?
Essentially, firms don't
account for the spillovers
that their investments
have on others.
So a great example
used in the book
is the example of when
two drug companies were
racing to invent statins.
You guys are too young
to know about statins,
but statins are basically
a cholesterol-lowering drug
that's a miracle.
It saves hundreds of
thousands of lives every year.
Best guess is
about 200,000 lives
a year are saved by people
lowering their cholesterol
through being on statins.
Statins were being
invented in the early 1980s
by two rival drug companies,
Merck in the US and Sankyo
in Japan.
And they were racing to
develop these statins.
And then Sankyo
suddenly stopped.
And Merck found out
through the grapevine
it was because some
dogs got sick in drug--
in the animal trials.
And so Merck went
to Sankyo and said,
hey, we heard some
dogs are sick.
What's going on?
Sankyo said we're not
going to tell you.
You're our competitor.
So Merck offered
to pay them money.
They offered to partner.
Sankyo said no way.
This is private
R&D, and we don't
want to share it with you.
So Merck stopped too.
Five years later, some
academics got permission
to run trials on statins.
It turns out that what happened
to the dogs had nothing
to do with the drug.
They were fine.
It's totally safe.
And statins were invented and
save 200,000 lives a year,
but five years after
they should have.
Literally, one
million people died
because there was--
they could not
benefit from the spillovers
of R&D knowledge, OK?
This is an example of what
we mean by under-investment
in R&D, OK?
So we have externalities
can be negative or positive.
They can be production
side or consumption side.
Questions about that?
Yeah?
STUDENT: So, regardless if
they're negative or positive,
externalities still
create deadweight loss.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yes,
regardless if they're
negative or positive,
externalities still create
deadweight loss because,
if they're positive--
I should-- Jason,
just sent me a note.
Next year, we should have in
the handout a positive graph.
Well, I'll just do it here.
I can-- I'm capable
of drawing a graph.
So let's think about R&D. OK,
here's the quantity of R&D, OK?
Here's the cost of
R&D, the price of R&D.
So basically-- and here's the--
so here's going to be
the demand for R&D, OK?
Here's going to be
the demand, which
is private marginal benefit.
And here's the supply, which is
the private marginal cost, OK?
And let's just say
that there's no
externalities from actually--
this is a consumption
externality.
This is a production
So, basically, the point is
that, when a firm does R&D,
they do it until the
benefits to the firm
equal the costs to the firm.
So they do an optimum-- they do
an amount of R&D of, you know,
Q1 at a price of P1.
But what they're missing is
that, in fact, what they're
missing is that
the costs to them
are actually well
below, well below,
what it truly costs because
they are benefiting others
by doing it, OK?
So the supply curve, the
true social supply curve,
is down here.
The social marginal cost is
the private marginal cost
minus the social benefits that
we get from doing that R&D.
So, as a result, they should be
doing Q2 R&D, but they're not.
They're doing too
little R&D. And that's
making a deadweight loss.
The deadweight loss,
remember, is with reference
to the optimal point.
This is the deadweight loss.
This is deadweight loss
from under producing
R&D. The difference between--
no, I'm sorry.
I got that wrong.
These triangles are
always confusing.
In the drawing,
I got that wrong.
OK, it's the difference being
the social marginal cost,
between the social
marginal cost,
and the private
marginal benefit.
So, basically, let me think
about this for one second.
This is always a
little bit hard to do.
So, basically, there are units--
there are units
they under produce.
So, essentially, what their--
they should be producing this
many units, yeah, between the--
it's where the private
marginal-- yeah, it's this.
I had it right.
That's the deadweight loss, OK?
Yeah, so, basically,
what you have is
you're going to have
underproduction of R&D,
just like you had
overproduction of steel, OK?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Why would the
social marginal cost
go down when the social
marginal benefit goes up?
JONATHAN GRUBER: Because
the marginal benefit
is what's the marginal benefit
of another dollar of R&D.
That's basically--
that's, essentially, what's
the knowledge created, OK?
You could view this either
way, but the idea here
is I'm producing R&D.
I'm not consuming R&D.
This is the benefit
of consuming R&D. This
is sort of the benefit
of society of consuming
that R&D. So you think of it as
lowering the cost of producing
the R&D is sort of the
way we think about it, OK?
But the main thing is not--
yeah?
STUDENT: So is the
marginal change
between the social curve and the
private curve, is that linear?
Or, as it grows--
JONATHAN GRUBER: That's
a great question.
I'm always making it--
I'm making it constant.
I'm assuming marginal damage or
marginal benefits are constant.
STUDENT: So, mathematically,
whichever triangle
you choose is the same?
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yeah, exactly,
because I'm making it constant.
And, in fact, you
could imagine it could
be growing or shrinking, OK?
Now, with this in
mind and realizing
that private sector can't
solve this for the reasons
we talked about, let's
talk about the role--
let's talk about the
role of government,
government solutions.
So, once again,
remember the basic logic
of this class, which is that--
the basic logic of the
class, which is that if--
the basic logic of the class
is that the market knows best
unless there's a market failure.
If there's a market
failure, the private market
will deliver a deadweight loss.
Now we have to ask can the
government actually make it
better.
Remember, we talked about
monopoly regulation.
The government may or may
not make it better, OK?
Information asymmetries, it
may or may not make it better.
Same thing with
externalities, the government
may not make it better.
So let's talk about how
the government, in theory,
could make it better, OK?
Well, there's two
ways the government
could make it better.
One way is by regulation.
So go back to figure 22-1, OK?
The government could
literally regulate
and could say, look, we know
the optimal level of steel
to be produced is Q2.
We're just going to
tell you to produce Q2.
That's it.
Problem solved, OK?
We just say, hey, steel plant,
we know the optimum is Q2.
You produce Q2.
Problem solved.
The problem with that is
that requires the government
to know quite a lot.
The government needs
to know both the supply
and the demand curves to
figure out where Q2 is
and what they should regulate.
Let's say all the government
knows is the damage being done,
and let's say the
damage is linear,
or they can approximate
it as linear.
Then there's a much
easier solution,
which is a corrective tax.
What if the government
came in and said,
look, I don't where demand
and supply curves are?
I don't really know.
It's really hard
to figure it out.
All I know is that, for every
unit of steel you produce,
which is a unit
of sludge, you're
killing $100 worth of fish.
That's what I know.
That I can study
environmentally, OK?
What if I simply
tax the steel plant
by $100 for every unit
of steel they produced?
That is, if I imposed a
tax on the steel plant--
STUDENT: Don't you mean sludge?
JONATHAN GRUBER:
One unit of steel
is one unit of sludge
in this example.
So I'm going to tax every
unit of steel they produce,
which is the same as producing
one unit of sludge, OK?
What if I impose that tax?
Well, let's look at figure 22-3.
What does that do to
the firm's decision, OK?
Well, before the
government came in,
the firm was
producing at point A
where their private
marginal costs equaled
the private marginal
benefit, which
is the social marginal benefit.
Now the government comes
in and levies a tax.
It levies a tax at exactly
MD, the marginal damage.
What does it do?
It shifts their private
marginal cost curve
to the social
marginal cost curve.
It has caused the firm to
internalize the externality
because now the firm is
paying an amount exactly
equal to the damage
they're doing to society.
So a corrective tax
can cause the firm
to internalize the externality.
Corrective tax caused the firm
to internalize the externality,
OK?
Essentially, a corrective
tax by the government
can get us to the right
answer because it gets firms
to do the right thing, OK?
It gets firms to pay attention
to the social costs, not just
the--
not just the private costs.
Similarly, we
could do same thing
with a positive externality.
What could the government do
with a positive externality?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Subsidize production.
JONATHAN GRUBER: It
could subsidize by--
so imagine I knew
exactly how much social
benefit there was per unit
of R&D. If I subsidized
the firm doing R&D, then I
would lower their costs, right?
If I offered them a
subsidy of this amount,
their cost curve
would shift down.
I would lower the cost.
So R&D would get
to the right point.
So a corrective tax of
the amount of damage
gets firms to internalize
the externality.
A corrective subsidy
of that amount
gets firms to internalize the
externality or individuals
to externalize the internality.
And we can get to
the optimal outcome
by the government
imposing a corrective tax
or subsidy of the right amount.
Now we could of course also
get there with regulation.
It's just a lot harder.
Questions about that?
OK, this is our first
example of good taxes, OK?
Taxes have been bad
throughout this course.
The role of taxes has been
distortionary to the economy.
We haven't talked
about it a lot.
We'll talk about it more
in a couple of lectures.
They've been distortionary
to the economy.
This is saying, no,
a tax can actually
play a positive role because
a tax can correct a market
failure.
Now, as always, if the
tax is set incorrectly,
it could make things worse.
OK, if you set a tax that was
five times the marginal damage,
it would make things worse.
But, if you set it correctly,
it can make things better.
We're offering the potential
for government intervention
to make things better here.
Questions about that?
OK, so what do we have?
We have a situation where
the private market is not
delivering the optimal outcome.
The private market is not
delivering the optimal outcome
where it seems hard to
think of private solutions,
but where a government solution,
either through regulation
or easier corrective
taxation, can get us
to the optimal outcome.
So now let's ask how does this
actually work in practice.
And let's talk
about two examples.
Let's talk about environmental
externalities and health
externalities.
Start with environmental
And, of course,
the most important
is global warming, OK?
Currently, the amount of carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere
is at its highest
level in 400,000 years.
Basically, every year becomes
the hottest year on record
almost linearly.
Almost monotonically, every year
is the hottest year on record.
We're heating up.
Scientists predict
that it's possible--
the central prediction
is that temperatures
will rise by more than 2 degrees
Fahrenheit by the end of the--
I'm sorry, by more
than 2 degrees Celsius
by the end of the century, but
it could be more than that.
There's actually,
currently, the best estimate
is that there's as
much as a 10% chance
that temperatures
go up by 10 degrees
by the end of the
century, which would
end human life, basically,
in most of the world, OK?
There is a non-trivial chance
we're all gone by 2100,
not my problem, largely
not your problem,
certainly your
kids' problem, OK?
OK, by and large,
we are basically--
we are basically-- we have a--
we know for sure there's going
to be negative implications.
Basically, we are essentially--
unless there's a radical
new technology invented,
Bangladesh is gone.
It's over for Bangladesh.
Cape Cod is gone.
Much of Florida is gone.
That's already happening, OK?
At this point, the
question is can we actually
stop the entire East and West
coasts and much of the South
from disappearing as well
and many other countries
in the world from
disappearing, OK?
That's the sort of decision
we have to make now, OK?
So, basically, this is a
classic negative externality
because, that
negative situation,
you were not thinking about
that when you filled up
your car last time.
You're not thinking
about the fact
that the fossil
fuels you're emitting
are contributing to that, OK?
It's a classic
negative externality.
So what can the government do?
Well, the natural solution
would be corrective taxation.
The natural solution would
be to have a carbon tax,
to literally say this is
the amount-- we actually
have a pretty good sense
from engineering models what
the cost of carbon is, what the
marginal cost of carbon is, OK?
And we could
literally impose a tax
on the use of carbon
of that amount.
I think it would
amount to something--
I don't know the
numbers these days.
It's something like between
$0.25 and $0.50 a gallon
of gas.
So it's a lot, but it's not--
we've seen gas prices
in the last year
go up and down by that much.
OK, that's not an
outrageous amount, OK?
In Europe, they already
have gasoline taxes
well above that level, OK?
So corrective taxation, in
principle, could be the answer.
We could literally just
use engineering models
to compute the costs,
social costs of carbon.
We could put a tax on it.
And then at least we would stop
global warming going forward.
You know, Bangladesh
may be gone,
but we can maybe save a lot
of the rest of the world, OK?
So that's in theory.
In practice, in
1994, Bill Clinton
proposed a $0.03 gas tax
and lost Congress, OK?
In practice, people
don't like gas taxes.
It's very hard politically
in the US and other places.
And that is why the world has
turned to a different approach,
which is quantity
regulation, which
is say, look, in practice, we
should have a global carbon
tax.
In theory, we should
have a global carbon tax.
In practice, that's hard.
That's why we have negotiations.
That's why we try to
have a global negotiation
to try to get a global
cap on carbon emissions,
actually have a quantity
regulation, to actually have
a quantity regulation.
We started this.
The first true
global negotiation
was in Kyoto, Japan
in December 1997.
I was fortunate enough to be
there for that negotiation.
I was in the Clinton
administration at the time.
And we got to go over
and do that negotiation.
It was actually pretty
neat because they decided
I was going at the last
minute, and the only plane left
to go on was Air Force Two.
So I got to fly over with the
vice president on Air Force
Two, which was pretty
cool, super cool.
They have really
nice seats and stuff.
And so I sat down, and
the phone next to me rang.
And I was like--
I answered it.
I was like hello.
They're like, hey, John.
I'm like oh my god.
It was them calling from
Japan, but like getting
a personal phone call on
a plane was super cool.
So, anyway, so I
went over to Kyoto.
I learned how these negotiations
work, which is, over five days,
I slept four hours.
In Japan, they sell--
they sold, at the time,
this coffee in cans.
So you just chug these
cans of coffee all the time
and stay awake.
And, basically, everyone is
so tired by the end they just
agree just to kind
of get it done.
And that's sort of way
that negotiations work.
So we agreed to the
Kyoto global warming
treaty, which would have
lowered emissions worldwide,
but the US did not sign on.
The US refused to sign on.
There's been continuing
negotiations.
Most recently, we know about
the Paris round of negotiations,
which the US did sign on to,
but the current administration
has pulled us back out of.
So we have a problem, which
is that, basically, we're
heading to this
environmental catastrophe,
and the world can't
agree on actions to take.
And it's not really a choice.
I mean, we have to do something,
or our grandkids will all
be under water, or
our great-grandkids
will all be under water.
We have to do something.
The optimistic case
that we'll do something
comes from the example of what's
called chlorofluorocarbons.
When I was a kid,
many, many products
were made with what's
called chlorofluorocarbons.
They were in refrigerators.
They were in aerosol
sprays, et cetera.
Scientists realized
they were actually
damaging the ozone
layer, which protects us
from ultraviolet
rays from the sun.
And people were
like, yeah, whatever,
much like they are with global
warming now, yeah, whatever.
But then a fucking hole
opened up in the ozone layer.
Like, literally, it was
like, oh my god, there's
a hole in the ozone layer.
And 180 countries got
together almost overnight
and banned chlorofluorocarbons.
Like, literally, almost
overnight, they were gone.
It was amazing,
international cooperation,
terrific international
cooperation
to take an environmental
catastrophe on and deal
with it.
The problem is global
warming doesn't quite
work that way, OK?
By the time we say, oh my god,
Bangladesh is under water,
it's too late.
So the question
is sort of how do
we get politicians
and the public
interested in taking something
on when we don't have
the symbol, like a hole
in the ozone layer,
to actually represent the
damage that's being done.
And that is the challenge facing
something like global warming,
but we have to take it on, OK?
So that's environmental
externalities.
The other big type
of externalities
are health externalities,
are health externalities.
I talked about smoking,
but, indeed, there
are huge externalities levied
by a bunch of activities
that we do that
impact our health.
So, for example,
drinking, drunk driving
causes 13,000 deaths per
year, 13,000 deaths per year,
OK, to put a sort of blunt face
on it, four 9/11s every year
from drunk driving plus
400,000 injuries every year
from people driving drunk.
Consuming gasoline, global
warming is a huge externality.
Perhaps one of the biggest
externalities facing us,
the biggest social
externality, is obesity, OK?
Obesity causes a
lot of illnesses
that cost a lot of money.
Projections are that children
born in the year 2000,
so about your kid, about your
generation, one third of them
will get diabetes before they
die based on current weight
projections.
Now, as you notice,
looking around this room,
that's not a problem of the
elite East Coast people, OK?
It's not a problem of-- it's a
problem of the less educated.
It's a problem concentrated
more in the South,
but, nonetheless, if you look
at a number of southern states,
the obesity rate is above 35%.
Literally, more than one in
three people in the state
are obese, OK?
This is a huge problem, and it's
going to cause huge social--
it's going to have huge social
consequences for our country.
The question is what
do we do about these.
What do we do about things
like smoking and drinking
and obesity?
And there's essentially--
there's, essentially,
four answers.
The first is information.
Can we just inform
people about the damages?
And, indeed, this has been
shown to work with smoking.
OK, we knew smoking was bad
for you in about 1954, OK?
But we only really
got through to people
starting really in
the 1970s and '80s,
but it's had an enormous effect.
Smoking has fallen
incredibly in the US
through that information.
But here's the
interesting thing, OK?
Smoking rates-- smoking used
to be 50% in the entire--
every adult, 50% of
all adults smoked.
It didn't matter race,
gender, class, whatever.
Now smoking is
essentially down to zero
among the well-educated
and still about 20%
against the less educated.
So information
works, but it works
in a very inequitable way.
OK, so information
is one solution.
The second solution is taxation.
And, indeed, this has been shown
to work for cigarettes once
again.
Smoking is price sensitive.
The elasticity of smoking
with respect to the price
is about minus 0.4.
About every 10% you raise
the price of cigarettes,
there's about 4% less smoking.
It works.
In particular, youth smoking
is very price sensitive.
Youths are very price sensitive
because youths have less money.
So they're very price sensitive.
So it actually works.
But that's sort
of the easy case.
Taxing cigarettes is easy
because every cigarette
is bad for you.
Taxing alcohol is trickier
because, after all,
most of the damage is done
by a tiny share of drinkers.
Most of us will consume alcohol
responsibly most of our lives
and not cause any
external damage, OK?
But most of the damage is done
by a tiny share of drinking.
So taxes is trickier.
If I proposed a big
rise in alcohol taxes,
people would say wait a second.
I'm responsible drinker.
Why are you taxing--
why are you taxing me?
So that's a little bit trickier.
Not to mention
obesity, taxing food
is maybe the
trickiest of all, OK?
So taxes are trickier.
You could maybe try--
an alternative thing you
could do is penalties.
So, instead of
taxing alcohol, we
could just steepen the
penalties for drunk driving.
You know, if you killed
a few drunk drivers,
there would be less
drunk driving, OK?
But the problem is that's
a pretty extreme penalty.
And what if you got it wrong?
You'd feel kind of bad
about killing someone
because the breathalyzer
didn't work.
There was a series of
articles, actually,
in The New York Times about
how terrible breathalyzers are
and how inaccurate they are, OK?
So problem with penalties is we
can't enforce them perfectly,
OK?
So that's the third solution.
The final solution and the one
that's really most discussed
right now is illegality.
What if we just made
these things illegal?
And this comes to the
discussion of marijuana.
Should marijuana be legal, OK?
Well, illegality is an extreme
form of lowering externalities.
Now, obviously,
when pot is illegal,
people still smoke pot.
But it's still true,
when you make it legal,
it's consumed at
much higher levels.
OK, legality does matter.
So, for example, people
have done studies.
Yes, people under 21
drink, but, literally,
if you look at people the day
after their 21st birthday,
they drink much more than
the day before their 21st.
Not on the 21st birthday,
that's the party.
We ignore that.
But, the day after their
21st birthday and thereafter,
they're drinking at much
higher levels than before.
Legality matters, OK?
It's also true, the day
after a 21st birthday,
people are much more likely
to die in a drunk driving
accident than the day before
their 21st birthday, OK?
So legality matters.
So the point is we
have a whole series
of tools to think about this.
And the question is how should
we combine and use them.
And the answer is
take 14.41, and I'll
teach you all about it.
But we don't any more time here.
This just raises the issues to
think about with externalities.
It's an important topic
to think about it.
I realize that's a lot
to cover in one lecture,
but I just wanted
to sort of give you
a taste for how
economists think about
and analyze this kind
of market failure.